it would be an understatement to say
that I am an absolutely huge fan of
Jonathan Roush it's the 20th anniversary
of his book kindly inquisitors kindly
inquisitors I really do put up there
with on liberty as among my favourite
defences of freedom of speech that I've
ever read it is concise it is beautiful
it is elegant and it is a moral defence
it's not a merely legalistic defense of
why free speech matters just to give you
a little bit of a sense of context
Jonathan would talk about how we've
turned into a society where there's an
offended to sweepstakes and just this
past month the University of Edinburgh
and five other universities in the
United Kingdom banned the song blurred
lines because they thought it was
offensive to women the university that
gave us David Hume is banning a Robin
Thicke song and and Jonathan Roush saw
this coming Jonathan is a senior fellow
at the Brookings Institute he's an
editor for Atlantic comm
he's written on everything from gay
marriage to how to take care of your
introvert I'm a huge fan and a little
hand off John thanks very much thanks
Greg and thanks for the great work that
you do at fire it's I'm John Tierney I'm
a science columnist for The New York
Times the author of willpower and a huge
fan also Jonathan's book this is
something that is it's not that often
that a journalist writes a book that 20
years later is even better than it was
then it is such a wonderful defense of
free speech and what's wonderful about
it also is that you take seriously the
objections to people who say that there
are two offensive species and you talk
about the different defenses there are
for why we should limit certain kinds of
speech and and you make a great
explanation as a science columnist I was
really intrigued by this about liberal
science being one of the three things
that Adam Smith's invisible hand gave us
there's liberal democracy there's
there's the capitalist system and
liberal science I do want to just start
by explaining what liberal Sciences I
would love to if you don't mind I just
want to take up a moment of personal
privilege and thanks to thank fire and
reason for this wonderful event I've
never spoken at the Museum of sex before
I have to say when someone hands you
this at the Museum of sex you do wonder
where it's where it's been but it's it's
and thank you all thank you all
especially for for coming tonight but
without the support of Greg and Matt
this revised edition the expanded
edition of kindly inquisitor's would not
have happened it very literally happened
at the suggestion of a fire staff member
who said you know that books 20 years
old and we love it and you really should
bring it up to date and bring it out as
an e-book and that's what set all of
this off so I owe all of you a lot of
thanks so liberal science of this was
born out of frustration during the the
Salman Rushdie affair of the late 80s
which you're old enough to remember and
that you know to the extent anyone was
able to defend freedom of thought at all
it was legalistic it was First Amendment
is what does the Constitution say
without understanding what we were
actually trying to do here I had a
background at Yale in history of science
and believed and and based on work I've
done and that others had done that
science is the third and actually the
greatest of our liberal social systems
the great problem in society is how you
deal with conflict if it's conflict over
resources you use markets and what it is
that you the token that you use is
exchange of of goods of commodities of
services in politics you're allocating
power and the mechanism you use is
exchange of compromise and votes well in
intellectual life the question is who is
Right who has the truth and you deal
with that through exchange of criticism
everyone gets to talk everyone gets to
put hypotheses out there all get
criticized there is no end to this game
it is a like all liberal systems it's an
open-ended depersonalized rule-based
system and at the end of the day
whichever hypotheses are still standing
is our knowledge always subject to
further change it depends on criticism
in fact it vitally depends on offending
people that's the foundation of it but a
lot of people had forgotten that and
they thought it's all supposed to be
people in white lab coats being nice to
each
well that's not really where knowledge
comes from and it's not the experimental
method that said science apart it's the
social method of finding truth yeah that
that's exactly right this is the great
insight of a philosopher named charles
sanders person anyone heard of him
greatest of all American philosophers a
few people have Wow he often came to the
Museum of sex I sure did
though he died in what 1910 he was early
they were kinky in those days you know
what they said about the Victorians in
the piano legs yes yeah so he was he
shouldn't interview me here it's not
safe uh feel free to offend anyone here
though he was way ahead of his time but
he was the first to understand that the
difference ultimately between science
it's the scientific enterprise writ
large that includes not just hard
science but the humanities it includes
journalism its historians its everybody
trying to find truth is not that you're
performing an experiment because you can
do that alone what he pointed out is
that if you've got a person working in
the privacy of his own room never
talking to anyone there's absolutely no
way to tell the difference even in
principle between Einstein and the
genius
excuse me between Einstein and a fool
Einstein and a raving lunatic you know
they're both scribbling equations on the
board and stuff the key test is do you
then subject those ideas to repeatable
public experiments and public criticism
such that anyone can have at them that's
how you know the difference between
Einstein and the madman it's a social
system for making knowledge and it turns
out to be fantastically good at two
things one is sorting finding the the
needles in the haystack those bits of
knowledge in the vast amounts of dross
that come out every day most of what
most people hypothesize is wrong
second it's very good at keeping the
piece because by definition no one can
be in charge of it it's a public
criticism system and it's a rolling
public consensus so you don't get the
Crede Wars
and you don't get the radical
disruptions that you do in authoritarian
systems of knowledge construction and
there are two laws to it you say right
yeah yeah no final say no special Tory
I've seen you've read the book yeah but
have you bought the book yeah I mean I
have to ask you about about the foreword
where George we'll just said he's stands
on the shoulders of giants of you so he
really it's and and all of us do but but
he said don't stand on the shoulders me
yes exactly that's heavy I know it's
very heavy we're in the music section
now he said your one fault with the book
was that you make a mistake that
temperate people may that they assume
that that their that the enemies of free
speech are as moderate and rational as
they are there Dan he thought kindly was
maybe too kind yeah he thought I'm
giving giving the other side other side
so to speak too much credit which was an
interesting comment so so that would the
the way to talk about that would be to
talk about who the opponents of this
system are and that's the the book is
divided into two halves for those of you
who have never actually read kindly
inquisitors in the original edition the
first half is about liberal science and
how it works liberal science our
knowledge producing system and these two
rules no final say no special authority
which are the rules of all liberal
systems voting markets the point is it
doesn't matter who you are no special
authority everyone basically follows the
same rules you get one vote each you
follow pricing signals you're subject
yourself to criticism and no final say
the system never comes to a final result
there is no outside platform from which
to say this is the right answer
you have to reach this answer so there's
no monarch there's no final fixed
distribution of goods or prices and
there's no final knowledge so it's a
liberal system open-ended rules base so
who does not like that well there are
some people who don't like it because
they're Hitler
or because they're the KKK but I would
argue those people are not most people
who don't like it most people who don't
like it are uncomfortable with it for
reasons that actually speak well of them
they think that the results of the
system are not fair for example if
you're an afro centrist you're going to
say this science has excluded my peoples
history for example I think that's wrong
but they're well motivated but more
important the the great challenge to
liberal science and the one that I think
has emerged is important over the last
20 years since the book was first
written is what I call the humanitarian
challenge I say they're too egalitarian
in humanitarian egalitarian say we have
a platform of fairness from outside the
system these results aren't fair so
let's change the results so you know
let's go in the schools and teach
creationism that hasn't done so well the
other is the humanitarian challenge and
those are people who are saying look
this system allows people to get hurt in
fact it often makes a point of hurting
people because it is criticizing people
and sometimes it allows people to behave
in hateful ways if you're gay you know
all about what it's like to live in a
society that is full of anti-gay speech
anti-gay thought why would we allow that
why would we allow for example racist
rhetoric this is hurtful it's
discriminatory the big change in the
last 20 years is a much more
sophisticated version of this which is a
it's a hostile environment doctrine it
says version 2.0 yeah version 2.0 I
wrote this afterward to this to this
electronic edition that says what's
happened in the last 20 years and it
says that the big thing that's happened
is it used to just be well Greg lukianov
offended me and that hurt my feelings
and I'm a minority because I'm gay
you're a homophobe we need to discipline
you and throw you out of this school or
re-educate you it's a good thing they're
not really saying that as much anymore
they're now saying look it's an
objective standard it's not did Greg
hurt my feelings it's is what he and
other
people saying create an environment a
social environment that's hostile to me
as a minority so I've said I can't
participate equally in society so that's
a new I would argue in different kind of
challenge and that's where I what I try
to take on in the afterword where I
I might disagree with George will is I
see these people as well motivated
misguided but well motivated and I think
in order to effectively counter them I
think we need to assume that - right
well I mean it's very nicely done on the
book the way you really give the other
side's argument you don't just flip it
aside
and you make a great argument in the
afterword using this against this
humanitarian idea the idea that there's
such a hostile environment that we have
to step in and and I'll let you explain
it more but one of the great insights I
like that you had There was that by the
time someone is willing to give a speech
code either a law or a speech code on
campus is willing to give you special
protection in a speech code or a law you
don't really need it anymore because
you've already got enough political
power and you tell a great example of
what's happened gaze over the last 50
years so when do you tell that well
that's the story you want to hear the
story yeah so I decided when I wrote
this did afterward to this book that I
would try to to take on the very best
narrowest most intellectually solid and
emotionally appealing case that the
opponents of unrestricted
thought and speech and debate could make
and to do that I look to a man named
Jeremy Waldron who's written an
excellent book that I can recommend
called the harm in hate speech which is
a very good but I should say
comparatively narrow doctrine of hostile
environment and it says so imagine as a
thought experiment that you're in a
society you're a member of a
historically vulnerable minority group
and you're in a society that is it's not
just occasionally some bum like Greg
lukianov saying offensive things that we
all have to live with that's free speech
no it's a society that is
literally festoon saturated with hateful
ideas and and diminution of minorities
and there have been such instances the
black space that in America for a very
very long time and I said well in that
instance they're saying well surely in
that case we can regulate for the
benefit of minorities so that they don't
have to live as second-class citizens so
I said all right that's a really tough
one that's the extreme case I said to
myself well what examples of that can I
think of and I very quickly realized
that I grew up in one I was born in 1960
you guys can do the math the hairline
says it all and I'm gay and in the world
I grew up in until really quite recently
the list is is endless
it's couldn't serve in the military
every form of government discrimination
every form of private discrimination
fired from our jobs arrested by the
police but more than that it was a given
in that society
it was saturated with anti-gay sentiment
with bigotry with the assumption that we
were sick that we were evil that we were
a threat to kids we were a threat to
social stability we were gross we were
sinful everywhere you looked
it was built-in it was part of the
background assumption of the society in
those days and then I thought well so is
there an argument for hate speech law in
a society like that but the question
answers itself when you asked yourself
in 1968 1955 1953 did you all know this
a u.s. senator shot himself in his
office because J Edgar Hoover was
threatening to out his son as gay as
part of a deliberate political plot by
Hoover and others to get this guy out of
the way I mean this was going on in
America it was really bad and I said
well you know you're not going to get a
hate crimes law passed to protect gay
people in that environment in fact
you'll get a hate crimes law that
represses gay people because our speech
will
be hateful and a threat to children
protects gonna be protect children from
this harmful speech you don't get hate
crimes laws protection fact you don't
even get to make the case for them until
after society has turned that corner and
is willing to hear your case so then I
began asking myself okay so if if hate
crimes laws are the cart
what is the horse what drove this change
and that's a lot of what the afterword
is about a lot of it is about an
incredible man named Frank Kameny some
of you might know him I see a few heads
nodding does anyone know the word the
name Frank Kameny oh well can we get to
that at please it's a great story please
tell the story about it right well I'll
finish the big point and then come back
to the small point
the big point is the reason we were able
to make the progress we were against
hate is that hate of this kind is not
usually motivated by people who want to
hurt other people it's not I hate you I
hate you I hate you it's people with
wrong ideas orthodoxies that are stale
that are discriminatory but they believe
these falses they believe the Jews
control the international financial
system they believe that blacks are
inferior and can't and our threat to you
know white women they believe that gays
are undermine the social order and try
to seduce children well if if someone
thinks I'm a threat to their children or
family they will hate me the way we went
after that was by exposing the wrongness
of their ideas by showing that we were
not dangerous or a threat and the way we
did that was by using to the hilt
the system of public criticism we called
liberal science and sure enough when
exposed to criticism these anti-gay
views they crumble
there were indefensible there was never
any evidence for them there was never
any coherence to them that's the
mechanism by which we triumph so I'm
arguing in the afterword that in some in
an indirect sense hate speeches
minorities friends it makes us push back
and in a climate that allows hate speech
also allows us to answer the hate speech
and we will win over time so how do we
win the story of Frank Kameny so when I
tell this story I get emotional I knew
this guy and it
hard to tell without but I'm fine I just
love to tell the story anyway so Frank
Kameny born in 1925 serves in the US
Army in the front lines in Italy during
World War two serves valiantly goes on
to get a PhD becomes scientist an
astronomer by training goes to work for
the US Army map service 1957 is caught
in a police sting and and I think
Lafayette Park in Washington DC and the
police of course were in the business in
those days of harassing gay people and
was fired from his government job as a
result because he had an arrest record
and he was queer he was gay on those
days if you were gay you could not work
for the US government most people in
that situation in the 50s understandably
crawled away some of them killed
themselves Frank Kameny was different
Frank Kameny fought back he appealed to
the u.s. civil service Commissioner as
it was then called it's now called the
Office of Personnel Management a point
we'll come back to they wouldn't even
hear the case they simply said this is
the rule he then went to Congress he
wrote letters he got letters back from
members of Congress saying things like
in all my years in this House of
Representative yours is the most
disgusting letter I have ever received
he then argued a case took the case
himself acting as his own lawyer to the
US Supreme Court they of course did not
grant cert but he wrote what's now a
classic brief Frank was a liberal in the
old school he believes that the
Declaration of Independence was a
promise that had been personally made to
him and that what had happened to him
was a betrayal of that promise and he
said so in the brief to the Supreme
Court he said I'm paraphrasing that he
said I went to Europe to fight tyranny
overseas only to come home and discover
that I must now fight the tyranny of my
own government against me
Supreme Court did not hear his case so
he then begins representing other gay
people who've been fired from their jobs
because
he's willing to do it and he knows the
rules he loses those one of those is a
employee of the member of Congress of
Library of Congress they were firing
people 1965 he leads the first gay civil
rights protest picketers in front of the
White House and picketers in
Independence Hall in 1971 he's the first
openly gay candidate for Congress he
forms the Mattachine Society of
Washington the first homo file group in
1972 he manages to seize the microphone
at the American Psychiatric Association
meeting in Washington DC and tells the
assembled psychic psychiatric
establishment to its face that they are
committing a campaign of extermination
against homosexuals that's how he puts
it this is Kameny crusaded for 30 years
to repeal the sodomy law in the District
of Columbia he did all of this and more
so then the gay marriage movement comes
along and he's too libertarian to be all
that interested in marriage and he comes
and he any kind of fades from sight but
all those things he did cumulatively
made a difference again and again you
know one of the proponents things of
proponents of hate speech laws say is
that hate speech silences minorities
well it silences a lot of members of
minorities but others it forces forward
it you get your Frank Kameny Xand the
great thing about liberal science is you
don't need that many Galileo's or kings
or comedies what it's great at doing is
surfacing these ideas testing them and
if they're better ideas and Khomeini's
were better ideas bringing them to the
center of the debate so the end of the
story and the part where I always choked
up is that Kameny lives to see the
following things happen he died in 2011
but by that point in 2007 his papers
including a letter from the Library of
Congress denying the appeal of the Fired
Library of Congress employee his papers
are accepted into the Civil Rights
Collection
the Library of Congress so that's fun
his original picket signs which survived
in his attic joined the Smithsonian
civil rights collection and are
displayed next to Jefferson's writing
desk he lives to see this gives a little
speech it was really fun in 2000 I think
9 he receives the pen from Obama when
Obama signs some federal benefits
partner benefits for civil servants in
2011 he's in the front road who watched
the signing of the bill overturning
Don't Ask Don't Tell but my favorite bit
is that I think it's 2010 he is given a
special ceremony in which the Office of
Personnel Management which is the
successor it's the same agency that
fired him was the Civil Service
Commission gives Khamenei a public
apology for his firing they give him
their highest award which is the
theodore roosevelt prize and my favorite
detail is that the director of the
office of publisher of public office of
personnel management who gives him this
prize is you can see this coming right
openly gay Kemeny yeah i mean what can
you say in the face of that kind of
courage Kemeny by the way at the
ceremony responds typical frank way he
says sort of rises from insurances
so this is the power of speech of
thought he didn't have money he didn't
have votes he didn't have anything he
had the power of ideas no what I love
about the book it I mean that's a great
story you tell and then you follow that
immediately by noting in its a caution
you have throughout the book that
there's a little bit of a fundamentalist
in all of us and and you raise the
question now the gay rights groups who
have you know have won have basically
won the public battle at this point I
mean in so many ways that they're
becoming intolerant some ways and you
raise you know couple examples for
instance when Apple when someone put an
app on Apple that promised to cure
homosexuality in 60 days through Jesus
and I guess it doesn't work I have to
tell you I haven't tried it but there
was an out - maybe I should try it
maybe but there was an outcry about this
from gay rights groups and Apple then
you know remove the app and then and you
and you know you're very fair even at it
maybe was that the right thing to do
yeah you know I think we need to be
really careful this is not a book one of
the things that distinguishes my book I
think for most of what's out there it's
not about law it's not about what the
Constitution lets you do it's about
what's wise to do and I think that we
gay people now that we have the majority
of the culture on our side need to be
very careful about remembering that the
reason what we were about in the gay
rights movement was not rights for gay
people to be ourselves to be true to our
conscience its rights of everyone to be
themselves and true to their conscience
and in some cases that's going to mean
letting foolish bigoted people or
Christians with terrible ideas often
hateful ideas ideas that are bad for
young gay kids but it's gonna mean
letting them do their thing
of course groups have a right to protest
an iPhone app and Apple has a right to
withdraw it I'm just saying I'm not sure
that's the smart thing to do you know
there's this movie opening November 1st
Ender's Game
anyone heard about this have you have
you heard about there's a boycott
movement some gay folks put up a website
so Orson Scott Card who wrote the book
on which the movie is based to set
anti-gay things some of which are pretty
terrible and you you know hard not not
good stuff and so some people want to
boycott it and I don't think that's a
smart approach for a lot of tactical
reasons you know it's not gonna hurt
Scott Card it's gonna hurt the people
who worked on the movie many of whom are
gay but also for the moral reason that
we need to remember we got where we are
because we were able to go mano-a-mano
with Jerry Falwell Anita Bryant Orson
Scott Card does us a favor by putting
those views out there and giving us a
platform to rebut them and giving us an
adversary by comparison of whom we look
better so it won't help us I think to
try to suppress these views I think it
will hurt us and the long-term result
actually is to bring more fame and
attention to these marginal characters
who are spouting this nonsense you talk
about in fundamentalist that there are
all kinds of fundamentalists and that
it's easy enough to say the other we
shouldn't be pushing creationism in
science classes and we should be careful
about these bible-thumping but the
really greater threat today is really
more from liberal I mean from left wing
fundamentalist now yeah what I had in
mind there is but I use fundamentalist
in a I captured I hijacked the term and
use it for my own my own sinister
purposes which are to I under mental
list is anyone who cannot take seriously
the possibility that he might be wrong
no matter how many times he's been wrong
in the past this time he is absolutely
for sure right
if you're absolutely for sure right
there's no point in liberal science
because all it's doing is allowing
people who are wrong to pollute the
environment with stupid wrongheaded
views usually evil views and yeah in
America we've seen a lot more of that
traditionally on the right so why did I
say these days I'm more worried about
the left it's because the environment
where we're seeing more of this happen
for reasons both cultural and historical
tends to be academia and it tends to be
driven by this view that minorities need
protection from discriminatory verbal
harassment this is something I think
there's a group in Philadelphia that
knows something about this and has been
known to work on it and I think they'll
tell you there's they're getting more of
this energy from the left and the right
would that be fair to say and the reason
for that isn't that left-wing people are
bad and right-wing people are good it's
that they've they've got this genuine
view that minorities have been hurt and
oppressed in American society which by
the way is true and they're trying to
create a campus culture that is friendly
to minorities and if you're sure you're
right and if you don't want people to
get hurt then it's only natural to say
well we're just gonna have rules and say
you can't hurt people by saying hateful
things here or by engaging in
discriminatory conduct which you then
define to include speech which is a form
of discriminatory behavior and then once
you do that you've got the whole
apparatus of you know kind of speech
inquisitions and disciplinary codes and
people get worried about having an open
classroom conversation about whether
homosexuality is morally acceptable for
example so yeah these days I think
there's more problems on the left but it
will change one thing I would love to
get out of kindly and people to get out
of kindly inquisitor's is this is not
left-right this is as long as we have
liberal science an open-ended public
process for finding knowledge a lot of
people will be unhappy with it just as
they are with markets because it's it's
unstable on any given day anyone
can say anything but it's also
discriminatory big point of the book is
liberal science is very cruel to you if
you're wrong it doesn't put you in jail
but it marginalizes you if you're a
creationist in America today you cannot
get the time of day in any biology
course in any college in the country
your treat you're just like you know
you're a loser well that doesn't seem
fair if you're a creationist the way
liberal science works is it rewards with
prestige and attention people whose
views stand up to repeated critical
checking but that is not nice if your
views do not stand up to repeat a
critical check so you're always going to
get this humanitarian complaint well
what about poor Greg over here no I'm
sorry to pick on your designated
straight man for tonight but you know
this guy's being marginalized he's not
getting equal time in the classroom
there may be millions of people who
believes the things he believes yet yet
he's not he's being pushed to the
margins that doesn't seem fair to people
and that's going to be a tension in
liberal science forever as will be the
attention that this is criticism it is
hurtful do you know if you know anything
if you've looked at the literature on
the sociology of science you know that
we imagine scientists are boring people
in white lab coats with petri dishes in
fact as the great historian and
sociologist of science David Hall once
wrote in in science academic science one
of the greatest of all motivators is I
am going to get that son of a [ __ ] I
mean this is hand-to-hand combat
politely veiled
so it's not liberal science is not nice
and I will get prestige by by
overturning the idea of the last
generation so that yeah prestige by
overturning the idea of my book so how
about that's right I mean that's coming
right now it's right in New York Times
column about the wrongness of my book
you do have a caution about in talking
about the fundamentalist in all of us
you say that you've seen it and in sort
of libertarian free-market people now
this was the one idea that I thought
should have been cut from your book my
friends walked in to even talk about it
tonight but I'm gonna give you a chance
yeah well the publishers of this book
who I should acknowledge also with
immense gratitude or the Cato Institute
and the University of Chicago Press who
Co published this and back twenty years
ago when this book was published one
thing that impressed me about Cato is I
do have a section about about people I'd
encountered in Washington back in the
80s who I regarded as fundamentalists on
economic issues there was no amount of
evidence that could conceivably convince
them that any tax increase could ever be
good for the economy which strikes me as
an empirical question and thus struck me
as a dogmatic attitude but the point I
was making was to say even people who
pride themselves on being open to to
coin a phrase reason if we're not
careful we fall into dogmatism and the
the safeguard against that is not in
ourselves humans become dogmatic we
think we know the truth the safeguard
and that isn't being forced or pushed by
the conventions of liberal science that
if we want respect for our opinions we
have to expose them to criticism of
others we've got to put them out there
and potentially be judged wrong so the
point I was making is that even the
friendliest toward reason must and
should submit themselves their views to
checking and will do best in an
atmosphere where everything is is
subject to checking well in that spirit
I think it's time to put your ideas to
public check in here hi um in terms of
free speech when you talking about
boycotting a film isn't boycotting free
markets in play in free speech they're
not trying to ban it they're boycotting
it isn't that a valid response to free
speech
yes it's constitutionally protected it's
an age-old gesture of protest I'm
suggesting it's not necessarily wise if
what you're saying
in front of the theater is we disagree
with this or we think this is bigoted or
here's another point of view handing out
pamphlets that is probably better than
what boycotters often asked for which is
to have the thing withdrawn to say take
it away from us now they're entitled to
use their market power and their voices
to say make this go away or silence this
person or in the case of Orson Scott
Card they were doing a tertiary boycott
because they were going to they were
trying to punish anyone associated with
this movie regardless of their views and
I'm saying yes it's protected it's an
age-old tactic for people in the
position of gays today it's not a very
wise tactic what the anti-gay right is
doing now is receding to a second line
of defense having mostly lost the
argument in the culture about the
wrongness of homosexuality per se
they're now saying well gay people are
the new bullies the new civil rights
violators they are violating our
religious liberty and they are forcing
everyone to agree with them on pain of
like being fired from your job or being
otherwise otherwise harassed and
pressured and I think it's unwise for us
to feed into that narrative I think the
narrative we should be feeding is we
fought for the open society so that even
complete jerks can participate in it and
we will this is the spirit of Frank
Kameny Frank was for 50 years he was
active he was extremely confrontational
I once heard him at an event like this
go face to face with a person of the
Family Research Council and tell him to
his face if you think your God believes
these things about gay people I can't do
this with the mic because that's how he
sound if you think that then your god is
a false and bigoted ID I mean that's the
way he talked so so he was no shrinking
violet but in all the years of his doing
that he never called for anyone else to
be silenced
he called for himself to be heard what
is that impulse that comes over a group
once it you know
passes a threshold we see this in all
kinds of oppressed groups where they do
start bullying that they've got that
political power and they start doing the
kind of thing that was done to them I
mean do you see that as and and I wonder
is it too kind to call that a
humanitarian impulse it's really more of
I've got power and I'm gonna exercise it
now well George will might say it's a
power plan in some cases it is I think
some of what goes on in campuses is
people exerting power over other people
but I go back to something I alluded to
earlier I think if you're gonna pull out
bad ideas by the roots you have to deal
with the people who have the bad ideas
for all the best reasons you can't just
say you're a bad person and there are a
lot of good reasons for people to behave
this way and I'll give you one so if you
are a gay teenager in America and you
are being told that you can be changed
and that there's something wrong with
you you may not be an environment in an
environment that is all that permeable
to liberal science and public criticism
and this stuff can be very damaging to
gay young people so the impulse to
protect people especially kids from
these messages is strong and it's
founded in something very primordial II
protective Waldron's best example you
know in his book that really makes you
think about hate speech is you know what
if you're a member of a minority in a
country that has a big nativist movement
that's saying people like you get out
and you're kids who are eight ten years
old have to walk past those posters to
school every day how are you gonna feel
about that should that be allowed should
that be done to your kids so the
impulses here are both bad and good
there's some of the offended in the
Sweepstakes mmm-hmm but there's also
some genuine humanitarian protective
impulse and you've got to deal with both
John I'd like to introduce a new topic
that may or may not be in your revised
kindly inquisitors but it's one that
you've recently find out by buying
you betcha and I will and and as of
about 15 minutes ago I committed myself
to doing that you have researched and
written very thoughtfully on this topic
and that is the income gap which i think
is rapidly becoming perhaps one of the
most powerful important issues of the
day even if one doesn't quote believe in
it from a perceptual standpoint it
remains extremely important and I'd like
you to offer a perspective on your
perspective on the libertarian view of
the income gap debate which I'm assuming
you're familiar with the arguments that
would potentially make about it but you
will forgive me if I say we should have
that discussion afterwards the I've been
thinking and writing about that a lot
and I think that conservatives have got
to do a lot better on what's going on
with income equality than they're doing
because I think 2012 was the last the
last presidential election for a long
time in which this won't be a major
issue but I'd rather talk about that in
some other context if you am i I'm
intrigued by your discussion of what's
happened in the last 20 years one
observation I have is his son is in
fifth grade at a let's just say unnamed
hoity-toity school here in New York and
the the sort of coat of arms of the
school at the lower school that they
walked by in the hallways on multiple
occasions a day has a list of sort of
credos to live by and I can't remember
them all off the top of that my head but
they are redundant and they go something
like be kind be considerate listen I
don't think don't offend as one of them
but spiritually that's in there and the
overall ethos of even very low school
lower school education in my observation
is very much here to not offending not
god forbid bullying
you know Graham on the board of fire and
so Greg and I have discussed numerous
occasions whether this is permeating
down from you know the university level
to the point where you know people get
inculcated in this new ethos at a very
young age and so by the time they get to
college even if they know their quote
rights they're just not going to be
inclined to exercise them and so I
wonder if you observe that at all
and be you know what is someone to do I
have trouble I guess debating with the
head of school and arguing against
kindness or for or for bullying and when
the kids come home I like kindness and I
like respectful kids so how do you sort
of undermine the unstated assumptions of
a lot of this cultural stuff that's
permeating even to a very very low age
sorry to drone on um no it's it's a very
deep question and it's hard to put the
ants my view on this across and a bumper
sticker for many of the same reasons
that it's always hard to defend liberal
systems in which individuals get hurt
you know what about poor people in a
capitalist economy so this may come as a
shock to some of you but I'm actually
Pro kindness and I am I am NOT for
offending people gratuitously I think
it's rude and actually a lot of what
interpreted one way a lot of what the
poster in your is it son or daughters
son school said is is very old-fashioned
which is mind your manners I am a big
believer in good manners and in a right
and wrong way to treat people what what
I tell people is you want people to try
to behave in a kind and considerate
fashion toward each other and you want
to inculcate that but you also want
people understand that that does not
give them a right never to be offended
at what other people say that there's a
right
the responsibility and that the
responsibility is to be thick-skinned so
what I would like that school to also
say is try to be kind to people but also
you have an obligation to hear things
that sometimes you won't like so it's a
two-way street the other way I try to
come at this also not the easiest thing
to explain is that there's a difference
between what you want the individual to
do and what you want the system to do
you want the individual to be kind you
don't want the system to be kind you
want the system to be neutral you want
the system to tolerate a certain degree
of unkindness how do you police the
unkindness well it turns out people who
go out of their way to be offensive from
day to day we have a scientific term for
those it's jerk there are other terms
which would be home at home here in the
Museum of sex and those people self
marginalize pretty quickly society
polite societies call that for a reason
right it's very good at pushing these
people off to the side so I am all for
school saying mind your manners I kind
of liked the old gentleman's code that
colleges used to have in the old days
you know it was a very different
environment then but the rule was look
you know don't behave like a jerk and if
you behave like a jerk you know we might
kick you out or you might get punched in
the nose and that's too bad for you
so but it's hard to put that across
right because when kindness actually
means you have a right to expect
everyone always to be nice to you
different story um the old gentleman's
code was that a gentleman never
unintentionally gives offense and and
that way and the idea was that sometimes
you would that you had to give offense
in terms of your definition of liberal
science I mean the Internet makes it
possible for more people than ever to
put their ideas out there and be
criticized and participate in this
debate as you're defining does that mean
that we're entering like a golden age in
terms of a society truthfulness you know
because we have a tool now to foster
that kind of
because of the internet yeah yes and no
it's certainly more open and the amount
of critical critical attention that any
one idea can be exposed to on any given
day is staggering now this is what makes
these systems so fantastically effective
all of these market exchange based
systems they're able to mobilize
resources around the world in with
astonishing speed but know in a sense
that one of the things liberal science
was very good at was identifying the
best critics and rewarding them with
prestige so everyone can be out there in
the debate but Joe Schmoe on the street
and Stephen Hawking were not equally
entitled to prestige in their views of
particle physics some of those
gatekeeper functions which liberal
science in the journal system actually
did pretty well I think I wouldn't say
they're threatened but I do worry a bit
that remember liberal science is right
space but also responsibility based
we've got to abide by the results and
when people are better critics and have
better answers we've got to find ways to
recognize them for that you know they're
the ones who get the PhD in the Nobel
Prize and that sort of thing and to the
extent it gets harder to reward people
who are really good critics really
special products really brilliant I'm a
bit concerned about that how does it
come out don't ask me I don't know do
see a lot of people rise to the top who
and you know the model might never have
been noticed right I mean you get people
get attention for their ideas and it's
merited don't you I don't think so yeah
sometimes I mean I don't think we know
how this this plays out and in a sense
I'm not sure it matters because as long
as you keep the two critical rules in
mind no final say no special authority
the technology is always going to change
but I think I think the trend for now
three hundred years four hundred years
will continue which is toward ever more
openness and larger and larger networks
of mind getting involved we haven't seen
what's gonna happen when you take the
uneducated women of India for example or
China or Africa educate them and put
them on this network that's going to be
what another billion minds
many of them high-quality minds the
success of the liberal science system of
mobilizing and engaging thought and
minds on critical human problems is
astounding just astounding and it's only
going to get more so I think but how
concerned are you that that academia at
the same time that you know they're all
these new forces out there that academia
itself seems to becoming more
constricted I mean that's just the
speech codes but it's becoming more a
kind of one politically correct well and
and this political monoculture word that
you know there's free exchange there but
but everyone thinks the same way so
you're not really getting it nowadays
but now there are ways that things are
being tested outside academia but but
you worry about that about this
monoculture on campus sure you you
always worry about a monoculture in an
intellectual system but again there's
this wonderful group in Philadelphia
that has I think you know I think Greg
may disagree with me I'd like to hear
his answer this but I think things were
better than they were 20 years ago when
I wrote this book and the reason a
reason for that is that the Frank Kameny
zuv campus have started to push back and
they've now found advocates who will
speak for them and they are now
successfully challenging petty tyrants
and bureaucracies on campus and making
them think twice and that was not the
case 20 years ago when you had Starr
chambers completely one-sided
proceedings and terrorized faculty what
would you be I can't actually speak to
1993 because I fire was only founded in
1999 and I only joined in 2001 but I
gotta tell you like I don't think I'll
ever see a crazier than 2007 2007 that
was the year that the student got in
trouble for publicly reading Notre Dame
versus the Klan which is a case I talk a
lot about in the book just because the
cover was found offensive there was a
professor professor at Brandeis who got
in trouble because he explained where
the epithet [ __ ] came from and just
from explaining in the context of a
Latin American Studies class he was
found guilty of harassment I mean it was
just case after case in 2007 so I don't
know how about it wasn't like maybe 9
five it looked like it was pretty bad
but in my experience I will say that I
think things have gotten somewhat better
partially because people know that
there's consequences partially due
frankly to fire but I had never seen
things crazier than it was I'd say five
years ago is it a random walk I did that
that's really hard to tell I think it's
really closely associated with the
expansion of beer a beer bureaucracy so
nadine strossen who by the way attended
the recent cruise two years ago guess
that was harder to leave she talked
about like why she was getting questions
about hate speech codes even 20 years
later about like why people are still
asking her about hate speech codes on
college campuses thinking this was an
argument we default in one because as a
as the public you know these were
defeating the courts of law they were
laughed at in the court of public
opinion when politically correct speech
coats came on the scene in late 80s
early 90s but they're still around and I
think the reason for that is that a lot
of the philosophy and thoughtfulness
that Jonathan talks about has gone out
of it but it's been picked up primarily
by a less reflective less thoughtful
administrative class that kind of
applies it with a certain kind of
zombie-like mindlessness which is how
you end up with things like a case that
we just filed suit in this week a
student literally was prevented he was
ordered to stop handing out
constitutions on constitution day if he
got this on tape it was a test he wanted
to see if they if they really would tell
him to go to the free speech zone and lo
and behold as Pope hat put it that they
they obligingly be clowned themselves by
coming out and saying you actually have
to go a little free speech zone over
there so it's been taken over by a
certain sort of like bureaucratic
mindlessness that's making it I think
that some of the philosophy of it isn't
doing particularly well but I think some
of the practice is just sort of trudging
on yeah I think that's right that I'm
not nowhere near as close to it as Greg
but my perception is that the good news
is that the ideological missionary zeal
that once empowered the sort of sense of
righteousness that once empowered
intellectuals to say we've got to do
something about all of this rampant
speech out there has really died down
and Jeremy Waldron is an example of that
his
book is beautifully crafted it's a
narrow argument it's an intelligent
argument the bad news is we've seen the
bureaucratization sort of as a force of
habit it's kind of a background from in
academic life these rules that you've
now have just you've got to have
discrimination codes which involve
verbal harassment and verbal harassment
turns out to be speech that someone
doesn't like I'll just mention up a
personal experience about eight years
ago I was undertaking some work and
working with scientists on on climate
change and for my work I was named a
climate denier I was named one of many
people who are engaging in an attempt
allegedly to deny climate change in some
sense though it was an intent that they
tent there was to associate what we were
doing with Holocaust denial it was
unambiguous as well because there was
also discussion among some of these
people of a need to bring me and other
alleged climate deniers to tribal they
literally wanted to have Nuremberg
trials for climate deniers so so they
what they're released was they were in
some areas of science at least there is
definitely the positions are could I
just say as a general matter not in the
spirit of liberal science but but
remember the reason that people follow
the rules of liberal science is not
because we're all liberal tolerant
people at heart most of us are not we're
all mostly fundamentalists at heart
we're passionate people we think we're
right the reason we follow these rules
is because we have to and the reason we
have to do is that we've created a
liberal social order in which ultimately
the way you get reputation and fame is
by being proven right by subjecting your
views to the critical process some of
what these people are trying to do which
is stigmatize you for getting to the
wrong answer is probably not legitimate
some of it is legitimate because if
you're in a minority the majority will
try to say
this guy's been disproven this guy's
like a flat earther we know this isn't
true so part of that is legitimate how
do we solve that the debate goes on
that's how and if you're right and if
you have evidence you do what Frank
Kameny did and what Galileo did and what
so many others have done and you sold
your on the amazing thing about this
system is that these people who try to
throw up these smoke screens it usually
doesn't work very well usually you get
to the right answer now some people have
to suffer along the way I keep coming
back to Kameny you know I make him out
as a hero he died a poor man and he
never got another job after he was fired
for that one and that's not clear that
he really wanted one he became an
activist but he was unemployable for
years I mean you have to have courage to
fight for your ideas and the system is
not nice to you liberal science is not
nice it is not always fun but it is
amazingly effective and amazingly good
at getting people like maybe Julie and
Morris riled up to fight back push back
and argue back and that's what's going
to work if you're right so how many
people here are under 30 a few of you
how many of you have some crazy dream to
do something that seems completely
impossible a few of you how many of you
are instead going to law school
so I'll pass on to you the best advice I
ever got which saved my life which is
don't go to law school unless you want
to be a lawyer because that's what
you'll do if you graduate from law
school it's great to go to law school if
you want to be a lawyer but but I became
a journalist and I developed the ideas
for this book coming out of college and
you know I was interested in history of
science but what really lit my fuse was
the Salman Rushdie affair for those of
you who don't know this was a novelist
who who offended the Ayatollah Khomeini
of Iran who put a price on his head
and rusty went into hiding for many
years many people were killed as a
result not Rushdie as it happen thank
goodness
and I decided that I had to write the
ultimate book explaining why the Western
Defense of Salman Rushdie had fallen so
short I mean it was so confused it was
like well you know they are threatening
him with death and that's certainly not
good but then he did offend Muslims with
this impious book and you can't do that
I mean you know that's not good either
so at the end of the day we've got to do
a better living so so this book began to
take shape it was initially going to be
called Thomas's disciples after doubting
Thomases and being a defensive doubt and
then it was called The Skeptical Society
and I quit my job to work on it and
pardon me though those are several of
the names skeptical society and then I
quit my job to work on it I was working
with a publisher that said they were
said they wanted to do it and I finally
got it in decent shape after throwing
away two drafts and the publisher looked
at it and said I'm sorry this is still
not publishable and I can't lead you on
anymore this book is never gonna happen
so we're pulling out good luck so I
dropped it in the wastebasket because by
that point I'd been at it for two years
and I always demoralized and a great
writer I know read it
and said you must not give up on this
you need to see this through so I pulled
it back out of the trash and did another
draft and by now it was actually pretty
good it was substantially like the book
you now see and it now had the title it
now has so with that in mind I then took
it to an agent biggest agent in
Washington and not expecting much was
astonished when like two days later he
calls back and he says mind you this is
the big agent in Washington he says I
don't think I can get you a lot of money
for this book but this is an
extraordinary book this will put you on
the map intellectually this needs to be
published and I can do that so I was
tasting success three months later he
handed the book back to me and said I'm
really sorry I couldn't even give this
away he said I got one offer no he said
I got one nibble from Atlantic Monthly
press ironically enough and I said give
me an offer in the four low four figures
John Tierney laughs he's in the business
and he said they still wouldn't do it so
at that point I really did decide I'd
had it you know I was 3 years in on this
book and it was by then a really good
book and no one knew what to do with it
or even what it was and you know Gregg
lukianov wasn't even born so the
audience hadn't even arisen so I just
finally said well better than nothing I
took it to my friend David Bose at the
Cato Institute you all know David some
of you a great man
he's revising his own great book
libertarianism a primer so watch for
that and I said and he said well we like
this we'll bring it out as like a
think-tank book you know one of those
little things think tanks do and I said
well that's great that's better than
nothing I sold him the rights lock stock
and barrel for a few thousand dollars
because that's how their business model
worked so you'll be interested to know
that all I ever got for this book was
that one check we fixed that in the
expanded edition
but then David said you know we
co-published sometimes with University
of Chicago Press Chicago is not only the
world's biggest but also the world's
most important publisher in philosophy
of science and history of ideas they
published Hayek they published the
structure of scientific revolutions Kuhn
and so forth popper they liked it they
put it through peer review which made it
a better book they published it as a
Chicago book it wound up being reviewed
on the front page of the New York Times
Book Review and now is going into its it
has never been out of print in 20 years
and it's now going into an expanded
edition and I expect it to be around in
20 more years and what I what I tell
people as a result of this is if you're
under 30 and there's something you
really want to do then by god you may be
right
35 if you don't have a mortgage and kids
you can probably pull it off well that
is a great note to end on thank you
thanks very much the reason for
confidence thank you John thank you
reason thank you fire